E
HERE TODAY- FROM- AMBER BRIDGER
ARE AT THIS POINT WE HAVE
TESTED MORE THAN THIRTY NINE
MILLION AMERICANS AMONG THOSE
OF MORE THAN THREE MILLION
AMERICANS HAVE TESTED POSITIVE
AND MORE THAN ONE POINT THREE
MILLION AMERICANS. HAVE
RECOVERED. SADLY MORE THAN A
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
AMERICANS HAVE LOST THEIR LIVES
AND OUR SYMPATHIES. ARE WITH
ALL OF THE IMPACTED FAMILIES.
AND WHILE WE MOURN WITH THOSE
WHO MOURN BECAUSE OF WHAT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE DONE
BECAUSE THE EXTRAORDINARY WORK
OF OUR HEALTH CARE WORKERS.
AROUND THE COUNTRY. WE ARE
ENCOURAGED- THAT THE AVERAGE
FERTILITY RATE CONTINUES TO BE
LOW AND STEADY. AND IT DAYS
EARLIER THIS WEEK WAS ACTUALLY
90% LOWER. THAN AT THE HEIGHT
OF THIS PANDEMIC. AGAIN IT'S A
CREDIT TO THE SACRIFICES THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE MADE. YOU
SURE THREE WORKED AT OUR YOUR
WORKERS ARE DOING AND- AND WE
PLEDGE THIS TASK FORCE WORKING
PART. GOVERNORS ALL ACROSS
COUNTRIES AND CONTINUE TO WORK
OUR HEARTS OUT. TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
OUR LOSSES. LOVE IN JUST A FEW
MOMENTS- DR DEBORAH BERKSHIRE
WILL OUTLINE THE DATA THAT
WE'RE SEEING AROUND THE COUNTRY
WE'RE TRACKING LITERALLY STATE
BY STATE. A COUNTY BY COUNTY-
BUT AS SHE WILL DESCRIBE IN A
MOMENT WE'RE ACTUALLY SEEING
EARLY INDICATIONS OF THE
PERCENT OF POSITIVE TESTING
FLATTENING. IN ARIZONA AND
FLORIDA AND TEXAS. GOVERNORS IN
EACH OF THOSE STATES HAVE TAKEN
STRONG STEPS- TO FLATTEN THE
CURVE AND AGAIN. AS DR BURCHELL
DESCRIBED WE'RE BEGINNING TO
SEE EARLY. INDICATIONS THAT
POSITIVITY IS FLATTENING AND IN
ARIZONA AND FLORIDA- WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE OF DECLINING
NUMBERS OF EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS AS WELL. WE BELIEVE THE
TAKE AWAY FROM THIS FOR EVERY
AMERICAN PARTICULARLY IN THOSE
STATES THAT ARE IMPACTED HIS-
SKIN DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
BECAUSE WE'RE STARTING TO SEE.
OF THE FIRST INDICATIONS- THAT
AS WE WERE ABLE TO DO- IN THE
NORTHEAST AS WE WERE ABLE TO
DO- IN NEW ORLEANS AND
LOUISIANA MICHIGAN AND OTHER
PLACES AROUND THE COUNTRY. FOR
PUTTING INTO PRACTICE THOSE
MITIGATION EFFORTS AND- WE'RE
BEGINNING TO SEE INDICATIONS
THAT THEY ARE HAVING A GOOD A
FACT WE ARE FOCUSED ON THE
STATE'S WHERE MORE THAN HALF OF
THE NEW CASES- THAT HAVE ARISEN
TEXAS ARIZONA FLORIDA AND
CALIFORNIA. AND HAVE RECEIVED
A- ENCOURAGING REPORTS EVEN
THROUGH THIS MORNING. STRONG
SUPPLIES OF PP AND HOSPITALS
HOSPITAL CAPACITY REMAINS
STRONG THE ONE THE THAT WE DID
HERE. ARE FROM GOVERNORS ACROSS
THE REGION IS FOR PERSONNEL AND
OVER THE LAST WEEK- WORKING
THROUGH FEMA THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND HHS WE'VE BEEN
PROCESSING. A REQUEST TO
DEPLOY- OVER A THOUSAND AND
SEVENTY DOCTORS AND NURSES AND
MEDICAL PERSONNEL. AT THIS
POINT OF ROUGHLY FIVE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE DOCTORS AND
NURSES ARE ON THE GROUND IN
ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA AND
TEXAS AND WE'RE PROCESSING- A
REQUEST FROM HER FOR AN
ADDITIONAL AMOUNT. BUT WE'VE
MADE IT CLEAR AS AS WE IF
YOU'LL RECALL WE DEPLOYED- AT
THE PRESIDENT'S DIRECTION
ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY MEDICAL
PERSON OFTEN YORK TO NEW JERSEY
TO CONNECTICUT. TO MICHIGAN THE
WE- WERE FROST OF DOING THAT IN
JUNE TO MAKE SURE. AT OF THE
THOSE DEDICATED DOCTORS NURSES
HEALTH CARE. BUT THE REALLY
THAT NEED AS WE SEE CASES
ARISING IN VARIOUS COMMUNITIES
ACROSS- THE SUN BELT AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK THAT. OUT WE
HAVE THE- CONFERENCE CALL
YESTERDAY WITH THE NATION'S
GOVERNORS- WE ARE IN THE
PROCESS OF- CONTINUING TO SEND
EVERY WEEK. A DETAILED COUNTY
BY COUNTY SUMMARIES ANALYSIS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO
GOVERNORS THAT ARE BEING- THAT
ARE BEING IMPLEMENTED AND WELL
RECEIVED. BUT WE ALSO ARE
ISSUING A RENEWED GUIDANCE ON-
PRESERVATION AND RE USE OF PP
AGAIN. WHAT WE'RE SHARING NOT
JUST SPEAKING TO GOVERNORS BUT
LOOKING DIRECTLY TO HOSPITALS
IS THAT- FRANKLY BECAUSE OF THE
HISTORIC EFFORT THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP IMPLEMENTED THE SPIN UP.
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
SUPPLIES OF GLOVES. AND MASKS
AND FACE SHIELDS AND AS WELL
AS- OF THE CONSTRUCTION OF
VENTILATOR TO NOT. FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND. AND OUR SUPPLIES. HE
WILL HEAR REMAINS STRONG BUT
WE'RE IN. HEALTH CARE TO BEGIN
NOW TO USE SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES THAT WE LEARNED IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY TO
OF- TO PRESERVE AND RE USE- THE
PP SUPPLIES- SO OUR OUR FOCUS
IS TO MAKE SURE OUR STATES HAVE
EVERYTHING THEY NEED. WHEN THEY
NEED IT AND WE'RE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH ALL THE GOVERNORS
TO MAKE THAT A REALITY WHAT
BRINGS US TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS- AS WE- AS WE SEE
TO THE NEEDS OF OUR STATES WE
FOCUS ON THE HEALTH CARE OF
THE- PEOPLE WORKING TO REOPEN
AMERICA. UNDER OPEN AMERICAN
SCHOOLS. YESTERDAY PRESIDENT
TRUMP CONVENED A SUMMIT OF
EDUCATION LEADERS AND HEALTH
OFFICIALS. AT THE WHITE HOUSE-
AND AS THE PRESIDENT MADE CLEAR
YESTERDAY- IT'S TIME. IT'S TIME
FOR US GET OUR KIDS TO SCHOOL
AND- THE SUMMIT YESTERDAY- GAVE
US AN OPPORTUNITY TO. TO
OUTLINE AND TO LEARN- WHAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO THAT IN
JUST A FEW MOMENTS AND ASK.
SECRETARY LOST TO TALK ABOUT
THE APPROACH DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. IS TAKING TO
ASSISTING LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND
STATES. AND BRINGING THEIR
SCHOOLS BACK ONLINE BUT ALSO WE
HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT REDFIELD
WHO WHO- HAS BEEN LITERALLY
SENSE. EARLY IN THIS PANDEMIC-
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO SCHOOLS
WILL BE ISSUING ADDITIONAL
GUIDANCE NEXT WEEK. I WOULDN'T
WANT TO PASS THE OPPORTUNITY
THOUGH- NOT JUST AS VICE
PRESIDENT BUT AS A- AS SOMEONE
WHO'S BEEN MARRIED TO A SCHOOL
TEACHER NOW FOR THIRTY FIVE
YEARS JUST TO SAY. TO SAY THANK
YOU TO ALL THE TEACHERS OUT
THERE. FROM EARLY THIS PANDEMIC
AND TEACHERS- LEARN HOW TO DO
THE DISTANCE TEACHING AND DID A
REMARKABLE JOB- OFTENTIMES
HAVING TO CARE FOR THEIR OWN
FAMILIES MAKE SURE THEIR OWN
CHILDREN'S THE STUDIES WERE
HAPPENING SO ALL OF OUR
AMERICA'S TEACHERS WE SAY THANK
YOU. WE ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE PARENTS. HEIRENS WHO
HAD TO STEP IN AND BECOME
EDUCATORS FOR ALL THEIR KIDS
IT'S REALLY BEEN REMARKABLE
WHEN YOU SEE. WHAT OUR KIDS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
DURING THIS. DIFFICULT TIME-
BUT WHAT WE HEARD AGAIN-
YESTERDAY FROM EDUCATION.
PEDIATRICS IT'S ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL THAT WE GET OUR KIDS
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM. FOR IN
PERSON LEARNING. WE CAN'T LET
OUR KIDS FALL BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY BUT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE-
REMEMBER- THAT- THAT FOR OUR
CHILDREN THAT THAT HAVE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. FOR SPECIAL
NEEDS CHILDREN- FOR NUTRITION
FOR CHILDREN IN IN THE-
COMMUNITIES FACING PERSISTENT
POVERTY THE SCHOOL IS THE PLACE
WHERE THEY RECEIVE ALL THE
SERVICES. AND SO THIS IS NOT
JUST SIMPLY ABOUT MAKING SURE
OUR KIDS ARE LEARNING AND THEIR
ADVANCING ACADEMICALLY BUT BUT
BUT FOR THEIR MENTAL HEALTH FOR
THEIR WELL BEING FOR THEIR
PHYSICAL HEALTH FOR NUTRITION
WE GOTTA GET OUR KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL- ANISH IF YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT YESTERDAY- AND THEN
AGAIN THIS MORNING WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY DETERMINED. AT TO
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP FOR STATE'S
OF TO GIVE THE GUIDANCE- FOR
STATES AND COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO SAFELY RE OPEN OUR
SCHOOLS THE CDC WILL BE ISSUING
GUIDANCE- NEXT. WEEK FIVE PART
AS OF OUR THAT WILL GIVE NEW.
TO OUR SCHOOLS. THE BUT WHAT
DOCTOR HE'LL MAKE CLEAR YES I'M
SURE MAKE CLEAR AGAIN TODAY IS.
WE'RE HELP. WE DON'T WANT
FEDERAL GUY TO THE A SUBSTITUTE
FORCED AND- LAWS RULES AND
GUIDANCE WE- WE'RE HERE TO
ASSIST. WITH THE SHARED
OBJECTIVE THAT I THINK IS
SHARED BY EVERY PARENT IN
AMERICA. WHICH IS WE WANT TO
GET HER KIDS BACK. WHEN I GET
BACK IN THE CLASSROOM WANT TO
GET OUR TEACHERS BACK IN THE
FROM OF THOSE CLASSROOMS WE
GOTTA GET OUR KIDS LEARNING IN
PERSON- ONCE AGAIN- AS
CONGRESS- IS THAT STILL IN
RECESS BUT WILL GATHER AGAIN
SOON WE ALREADY OR DISCUSSION.
THE DIVISIONAL POTENTIALS
ALTHOUGH WE WERE ABLE TO REMIND
GOVERNORS OF THIRTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS- IS
AVAILABLE IN THE CARE ACT FOR
STATES- TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST
THEM AS THEY ROLL UP AND
RESTART SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. PRESENT MOMENT. YES
ONE FIVE FOR OF THOSE FOR AND
DOWN. BY STATE'S WE ENCOURAGE
THE GOVERNOR TO TAKE. ADVANTAGE
OF THAT. OUR OBJECTIVES AS ICE
HOURS BLACK. MEET THE NEW OF
OUR- AND THEIR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS PROTECT THE MOST AND
SAFELY REOPENING. SAFELY RE
OPENED OUR SCHOOLS- AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS WE ARE. WE ARE
REOPENING AMERICA THE JOBS
REPORT LAST THURSDAY SPOKE FOR
ITSELF NEARLY FIVE. MILLION
JOBS CREATED. AND I CAN TELL
YOU EVIDENCE ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY IS THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE FINDING A WAY. TO DO
THEIR PART. TO PUT THE HEALTH
OF THEIR NEIGHBORS FIRST EVEN
WHILE WE ALL FIND A WAY TO GET
TO WORK TWO SHIFTS. THE END
DISK. AND WE ALL HAVE A ROLE TO
PLAY. TO SLOW THE SPREAD TO
PROTECT. MOST ONE OF AND THE
STATE'S RE OPEN OUR COUNTRY AND
OUR SCHOOL AND SO I WOULD JUST
I JUST CLOSE BEFORE I TURN THE-
OVER TO DOCTOR. FOR HER FORTUNE
SIMPLY THIS THANK TO THE RIGHT
PEOPLE. THANK FOR WHAT YOU'VE
DONE SO FAR. THANK YOU FOR THE
WAY YOU FOR THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING. OF NOT JUST FAMILY. AND
FRIENDS BUT BUT BUT STRANGERS
PEOPLE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW FIRST
AND WE JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO.
KEEP DOING WHAT YOU'RE DOING
KEEP HEATING THE GUIDANCE OF
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES
PRACTICE GOOD HYGIENE WASH YOUR
HANDS. WERE AMASSED WHEREVER A
STATE LOCAL AUTHORITIES
DETERMINANTS INDICATED OR WERE
MASS WERE YOU CAN'T ENGAGE IN
SOCIAL DISTANCING. THIS IS THE
ROLL EACH OF US CAN CONTINUE TO
PLAY. AND WE'RE SEEING SOME
EARLY INDICATIONS IN SOME OF
THE MOST IMPACTED STATES THAT.
AMERICANS ARE DOING JUST THAT
SO WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE YOU
WANT TO TELL YOU THAT. WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO OUR
PART AND I'M JUST ABSOLUTELY
CONFIDENT JUST AS WE PROVED
WHEN IT'S PANDEMIC WAS
STRIKING- SO DEEPLY IN THE
NORTHEAST WHEN IT WAS STRIKING
IN THE- LOUISIANA MICHIGAN.
PEOPLE. WHAT NEEDS TO BE. AND
WE KNOW WE CAN DO IT. AND
FLATTENED. WITH LATIN BEFORE WE
SLOW SPREAD BEFORE. ON WHEN WE
CAN DO TO. BUT WE'VE GOT ALL DO
OUR PART. AND WE'LL DO IT
TOGETHER. WITH THAT A DOCTOR
BERKE AND THEN WE'LL GO A
REPORT FROM AN- ARE BEFORE WE
ON TO REPORTS. THAT MARCH.
THANK AT THE RIGHT PRESIDENT I
COULD HAVE THE FIRST FLIGHT
POLICE. ON AND I KNOW SOME OF
YOU DO WHAT I. FIVE WEARING THE
SPECIALLY TODAY. ON THIS CAME
THE SALT TRY I JUST ONE AT.
MASS CAN BE A FASHION STATEMENT.
AT I WANT TO THANK THE SITE REP
DRIVE A WAS A- PLEASURE. TIM
OUT ON AND SPEAK THE END OF.
AROUND THE UNITED STATES ABOUT
THE ISSUES THAT THEY'RE FACING
THE COVERT NINETEEN. TO BE ABLE
TO MEET WITH COMMUNITIES
HOSPITAL. PERSONNEL AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITIES HISPANIC
COMMUNITIES AND OUR PRIDE
TRIBAL NATIONS. ON THAT WAS A
PRIVILEGE LAST WEEK I WANT TO
START WITH ARIZONA- JUST TO.
CUP WHERE THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEFT OFF THAT AREN'T LINE IS
THE NUMBER OF TESTS PERFORMED
ON THE BLUE LINE AS THE TEST
POSITIVITY NOW THIS IS THAT THE
LEVEL OF THE STATE- AND-
ARIZONA DOES HAVE THREE
COUNTIES THAT WE'RE TRACKING
VERY CLOSELY OBVIOUS YOU KNOW
THE LARGEST ONE. BEING FAMOUS
AND MARICOPA COUNTY. THIS DISH
DOES SHOW THAT THE BLUE LINE
WHICH IS A FIVE DAY AT SEVEN
DAY AVERAGE THANK YOU TO THE
DATA TEAM FOR THESE WONDERFUL
SLIDES. THE FIGHT THE SEVEN DAY
AVERAGE IS SHOWING SOME
FLATTENING AND THEY FIND THAT
ENCOURAGING ALSO EQUALLY
ENCOURAGING AT THIS POINT.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THE TEST
POSITIVITY RATE IS THE FIRST
THING TO INCREASE- AND WE'RE
HOPING THAT IT HERALDS A
STABILITY IN ARIZONA OF AT
LEAST REACHING. A PLATEAU IN
THEIR CURRENT THE RED LINE
REPRESENTS THE EMERGENCY ROOM
VISITS FOR ANY OTHER COVID LIKE
SYMPTOMS- AND THIS IS ALSO AN
EARLY INDICATOR- AND WE FIND
THAT ENCOURAGING THE NEXT SLIDE
DOES SHOW. THE COUNTIES THAT
WE'RE TRACKING OBVIOUSLY THE
LARGEST COUNTY BEING MARICOPA
COUNTY WITH THE LARGEST NUMBER
OF INFECTIONS BUT CLEARLY THERE
IS ISSUES IN YUMA AND CAME UP.
ON THE VICE MENTIONED THAT
REPORTS AGO TWO GOVERNORS THIS
IS WHAT THE REPORT- LOOKS LIKE
ITS SOURCE THEIR FULL SIDE PAGE.
ON THE ALASKA'S ON THE PAGE OUR
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT WE'RE
SEEING RALLY TO THEIR EPIDEMIC
I'M A SPECIFIC RECOMMEND.
RELATED TO WHERE WOULD WE SEE
THEM AS FAR AS BEING IN A
DANGER ZONE ECHOED IT. I YEAH
AND RED. AND FOLLOWS THAT THEY
HE ON EVERYTHING YOU'RE SEEING
ON THAT FIRST. AND BLOCK MORE
BOX AND THEN EACH THE COUNTS. I
REPRESENT SAID THAT THEY HAVE
IN ONE PLACE FIVE PAGES FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE AND TASK FORCE
THAT SUMMARIZES WHAT WE'RE
SEEING AND THAT GOES OUT
WEEKLY- NEXT PLEASE. THIS THAT
FLY. AND YOU CAN SEE THE IN THE
STATE WAY I AT THE RIGHT LINE
EARLY SUCH. I'VE DICK IT
EMERGED D. ROOM THAT'S WHERE
THE- EVENT AT THE BILL. HARDING
THAT BLUE HOPING. A STABILITY
AND THE NUMBER OF DAYS WROTE IN
CASE WE ALSO. STAND THREE. DAY
WEEKEND AND HOW WEEKENDS KIND
AND DAY ON AN- I REPORTING
THROUGH THE WEEK. AND THEN UP.
ON MONDAY TUESDAY AND WHEN. I
HOW WEEK. NOW SLIDE THAT SHOWS
THE COUNTY OF. THAT WE'RE TO.
THESE ARE THE TWO. TEN COUNT IN.
AND YOU CAN. EACH OF THEM HAVE
A D. PRO. I WANT TO CALL YOUR
ATTENTION THE COUNT THAT ARE
ACROSS THE BOTTOM THERE THAT
ARE MORE DIFFICULT TO SEE. SOME
OF THOSE REPRESENT-
JACKSONVILLE AND ARCH OTHER
LARGE METROS INCLUDING TAMPA.
WHEN THE GOVERNOR TALKS ABOUT
HOW THEY WERE STEADY AND LOW
FOR A LONG PERIOD OF TIME AFTER
RE OPENING. THIS IS WHERE. OUR
FLAG. ALMOST FIVE AFTER RE
OPENING CLEAR THERE WAS
SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED. THOUGH
AND THOSE THAT WERE LOOKING
INTO ACROSS THE BOARD BECAUSE
WHATEVER HAPPENED IN FLORIDA
HAPPENED ACROSS THE SUNBELT.
AND THAT ALL OF THE CURVES AND
ALL OF THE FINDINGS ARE MERE
AND IF YOU REMEMBER EARLY ON IN
MARCH AND APRIL AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT AT. FIRST THE NEW
YORK METRO. BYE BYE. FOLLOWED
BY. AND CHICAGO. AND NEW
ORLEANS WE I'M THE NEW METRO
AND SO THIS HERE HE'S- A
INDIVIDUAL. IN THE CASE WE-
OCCURRED HEARD ALMOST LIKE
KENYA'S LEE ACROSS THE SOUTH.
SO WE'RE TESTING. PLEASE THIS
IS THE ALLEGES. THAT CAN. ONLY
ONE SIX BUT ALSO HELP US IN
GUIDANCE TO THE MASS PEOPLE OF
WE'RE ASKING ON TO NEXT THIS.
AND YOU CAN SEE TEXAS IS IN A
SIMILAR IS. WITH THEIR BLUE
LINE AND WE'RE THE VERY CLOSELY
ACROSS TEXAS NEXT. BUT I THINK
I OF YOU KNOW THERE'S THIS. OF
MAJOR MAY. AND WAS SET INCREASE
CASE FROM HE- TODAY TO ANTONIO
TO EL PASO AND MICHAEL AIR AND-
THE GOVERNOR GET THIS TIE OF
ROOF. ON WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
AND THEN LIKE HOW OF YEAH.
WHERE YOU SEE I'M THE NEXT I
THINK YOU I'M A ALONG TIME AS-
BUT THEN THIS INCREASE AND THEN
OF TEN PILOTS. AND RAPID
INCREASE IN CASES SLIDE AND YOU
CAN SEE THE MAJORITY OF THE
ISSUE IS IN THE LOS ANGELES
AREA ALTHOUGH WE SEE THIS
THROUGH RIVERSIDE IMPERIAL
SACRAMENTO AND NOW SAN
FRANCISCO WITH INCREASED NUMBER
OF CASES. SO I WANNA FINISH
WITH WHERE THE VICE PRESIDENT
STARTED ABOUT THE SACRIFICES OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE BECAUSE IN
THAT RECOMMENDATIONS ARE VERY
CLEAR RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WHEN
YOU HAVE A COUNTY WITH THESE
TYPES OF CASES WE ARE
RECOMMENDING. EVERYONE USING A
FACE COVERING AND I THINK THE
STUDIES NOW THAT HAVE BEEN
DONE. SHOWING THAT COTTON FACE
COVERINGS I'M WORK THAT OPEN UP
THE ABILITY FOR US ALL TO HAVE
INDIVIDUALIZED FACED RATES AT
EXPRESS OUR PERSONALITY BUT IN
ADDITION I THINK THE WORK THAT
THESE GOVERNORS HAVE DONE TO.
ASK ERIC PEOPLE. THIS IS GOING
TO BARS TO CLOSE THE BAR TO
MOVE OUT TO DINING. TWO
DECREASE INDOOR AND KIND OF DO
ARE EITHER INNINGS TO GET. TO
ALL. OUT THERE THAT ARE IN NEED
FOR STATE IN THE STATES THAT
HAVE. THE REPORT WHERE THE RED
THIS IS A SERIES THE STATE HAVE
IN THAT. ONLY ACT AND THE GOOD
PEOPLE ACCOUNT AND IT DOES. IN
THE STATE'S NOT ONLY. YOU THE
DAYS COVER NOT GONE. IS NOT
GOING TO IN DYING. BUT REALLY
NOT GAP BRINGING IT HOME EITHER
AND DECREASE THOSE. DOWN FACED
RACKHAM DAY. COMMUNITY IN
PENNSYLVANIA- WHO WHO ARE
HELPED BY THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SERVICE AND THEY CANCEL THESE
FOR A LOT OF OUR OFFICERS TO
MATCH OUR- OPERATIONAL DRESSED
AS BLUE UNIFORMS SO. I WEAR
THIS PROBABLY AND I THINK OF
THAT COMMUNITY EVERY SINGLE
DAY. EVERYBODY PITCHING IN
ACROSS AMERICA HELP US ALL. SO
IN TERMS OF TESTING WHEN A
COVER THREE QUICK TOPICS FIRST
ONE IS JUST WHERE WE ARE
NUMERICALLY VICE PRESIDENTS ARE
HE SAID. WE ARE NOW TOPPING
THIRTY NINE MILLION TEST ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. ON THE STATE'S
REALLY CRUSH THEIR GOAL IN JUNE
OF THE STATE CALLS WAS ABOUT
TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION IN
JUNE. A CDC NUMBERS OUT HAVE
FINALIZED AT ABOUT SIXTEEN AND
A HALF MILLION TESTS FOR JUNE
SO CONGRATULATIONS TO ALMOST
ALL THE STATES TO- MADE THEIR
GOAL EXCEEDED THEIR GOAL. ALL
WE'RE DOING VERY WELL RIGHT NOW
BETWEEN SIX AND SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND AS PER DAY WE DID TALK
TO SEVEN. THOUSAND ALL. CAN
REMEMBER ABOUT A- HUNDRED AND
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE.
HAS PER DAY. WE CONTINUE TO
SHIP- WE ARE RIPE WITH SWABS
AND MEDIA SO. THE STATE'S TELL
US WHAT THEY NEED WE WORK WITH
THEM TO SET THOSE GOALS BASED
ON THEIR STATE TESTING PLANS.
ARE AFTER TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BY THE CDC IN MY OFFICE FEMA
SHIPS THOSE EVERY WEEK. ARE NOW
THAT'S ALONG WITH ASKED FOR
OBVIOUS ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
ERNEST RESPONSE. ON AT HHS SO
THAT'S SORT OF THE OVERALL
GENERAL VIEW. ALL RIGHT NOW
YESTERDAY OUR WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT A LITTLE BIT LAST WEEK
AND THAT IS FEDERAL SEARCH
SITES. WE THESE IN CAN. ARE
THERE WAS A LIST OF COMMUNITIES
IDENTIFIED BY DOCTOR BURKS AND
HER TEAM. THAT HAD CERTAIN
CHARACTERISTICS OF THEIR
INFECTION TRENDS BUT ALSO MET
CERTAIN CHARACTERISTICS OF-
NUMERICAL NUMBERS IN ISOLATION.
THAT SEARCH TESTING- MIGHT HAVE
AN IMPACT OVER A SHORT PERIOD
OF TIME. SO OUR GOAL IN THOSE
COMMUNITIES IS DUE AT LEAST
FIVE THOUSAND TESTS PER DAY-
AND THOSE ARE IN BATON ROUGE
JACKSONVILLE AND MCALLEN. ON
THE MIKE ON IN TEXAS- WE HAVE
MANY OTHER SITES ARE THAT WE'RE
WORKING WITH AGAIN THIS
PARTNERSHIP- WITH THE STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN- THERE UP AND- CASTED.
ALL THREES IT'S ABOUT
RESTARTING THIRTY. SITES START
A PARTY HAVE A ON SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED POINT. ARE MADE. SO
THAT VERY WELL. LET ME TALK
ABOUT IS PHOENIX AND I'M WE
HAVE. I GET JUST. CONCERN WHEN
I HEAR IN THE LIKE WE'RE DOING
NOTHING FOR PHOENIX IN THE
GOVERNMENT HASN'T ANYTHING
WITHIN A- BECAUSE THAT WOULD.
IS NOT ACTING IN IT ON. A LOT
OF THE THAT WE'RE I'M JUST YOU
SOMETHING. I DIDN'T MAKE THE
SLIDE UP MY TEAM THIS WAS PART
OF A FIFTY FIVE SLIDE DECK
FIFTY FIVE SLIDE SLIDE DECK. ON
PHOENIX WHERE WE UNDERSTAND THE
GRAPHICS HEALTH DESPAIR THE
INCOME LEVELS- THE RACIAL AND
ETHNIC C. BACKGROUNDS WHERE THE
TESTS ARE DONE WITH THE
RESOURCES ARE. THIS IS HOW WE
WORK THE IT IS SO FIRST OF ALL
WE'RE IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH
THEIR DETAINED. ON THIS DATE
THIS ROLES ARE. ONLY TWO CALLED
YOU'RE FREE. OUR REDFIELD DOES
THIS WELL AND IN BROOKS THIS IS
WHY. NUMBER TWO WE PROVIDE
ACCORDING TO THIS PLAN JUSTIN
TO MY WE SHIPPED OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND- SWABS- AND
MEDIA TO THE STATE TO FILL
THEIR PLANS. ON IN TERMS OF
PHOENIX IF I GET THE FIRST
SLIDE BACK PLEASE I JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT YES WE HAVE LOTS OF
SUPPORT IN PHOENIX- THIS IS THE
COMMUNITY BASED TESTING
LOCATIONS I DIDN'T BECAUSE THIS
BECAUSE IT'S RIGHT OUT OF MY
SLIDE DECK- PHOENIX HAS. THREE
FEDERALLY FUNDED RETAIL SITES
THIS IS A PAID ON A PER CAPITA
BASIS YOU COME OUT GET A TEST
THE SITES NOT THESE THREE SITES
BUT THIS OVERALL PROGRAM IS
TESTED JUST UNDER A MILLION.
INDIVIDUALS AND THEY'RE LOCATED
SPECIFICALLY IN COMMUNITIES OF
HIGH SOCIAL VULNERABILITY WE
HAVE THREE THERE. WE ALSO HAVE
THIRTEEN. WE CALL IT POINT OF
SITES THESE ARE CALIFORNIA IS
THAT BECAUSE OF OUR REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY THEY CAN DO THAT
ABOUT A THIRD. ALL RIGHT THAT
GREAT THEY DO THIS JUSTICE.
THANK YOU MEDICAID BILLING.
SAID THOSE SIXTEEN FEDERAL SO
HAVE IN PHOENIX NEXT. ON I
DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A MAP TO
GO WITH THAT BUT UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF SECRETARY AIDES
ARE WE'VE REALLY SURGED INTO
ACTUATES THESE ARE FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS ON
THIS IS WHERE YOU REALLY WANT
TESTING TO HAPPEN BECAUSE THESE
ARE MEDICAL HOMES FOR THE POOR
INDIGENOUS UNDERSERVED. WE
AFTER TWENTY EIGHT Q. EIGHT C.
SITES PERFORMING TESTING JUSTIN
THE JUST IN THE PHOENIX AREA-
RIGHT NOW NEXT SLIDE. WE DON'T
HAVE THAT SIDE THE LET ME TALK
ABOUT- WE'VE ALSO IDENTIFIED
EVERY SINGLE TESTING MACHINE IN
PHOENIX SO THERE ARE- TESTING
MACHINES TO DO. TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF TESTS PER DAY AND
WE'RE SENDING AT LEAST A
HUNDRED THOUSAND. OKAY MAYBE
IT'LL COME UP IF YOU WANT BUT
AT LEAST A HUNDRED THOUSAND
ESSAYS TO THE PHOENIX AREA
EVERY WEEK. THESE ARE ALL THE
THINGS WE'RE DOING IN THE
BACKGROUND THAT THAT HAPPEN ON
A REGULAR BASIS IS THAT WE DO
COMMUNITY BY COMMUNITY
COMMUNITY. NOW TWO DAYS AGO.
ALL I HEARD THAT MAYOR GUY YAGO
WAS UNHAPPY BECAUSE THERE IS NO
FEDERAL SUPPORT I HEARD ON
MONDAY ON. I WAS ON THE PHONE
WITH FEMA REPRESENTATIVE
AFTERNOON IT WOULD. BE THAT
FEAT WAS NOT INTO THE ALL THE
THINGS THAT THE- DOING. IN THE
IN THE CALL LAST NIGHT WHERE WE
HAD GOVERNOR DUCEY'S OUR PEOPLE
ON THE PHONE. WELL WE HAD A
MAYOR PEOPLE ON THE PHONE BUT
WE HAVE YES TULSA BONE WE GOT
EVERYBODY TOGETHER JUST DID.
WHERE THEY- ARE. A STATE. INTO
SITES PER STATE TEST FLIGHTS IN
PHOENIX THAT ARE UP THERE I IN
THIS MORNING GOV DUCEY LOOKED
AT EVERY THOUGHT I SEARCH SITE
WOULD BE HELPFUL IN WEST HE
REQUESTED AND WE'RE THAT RIGHT
SO I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
THAT EXAMPLE BECAUSE IT REALLY
PAINS ME SOMEBODY'S AS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ISN'T DOING
ANYTHING WHEN WE HAVE FORTY ONE
FEDERAL SITES THERE WE'RE
SENDING SUPPLIES WITH SENDING
PASS AND WE WILL PUT THE
GOVERNOR EVERY DAY AND IF
THERE'S AN APPROPRIATE PASSED
IN ALL THE WAY. AFTER BROOKS IT
WAS WE'LL SEND A CERTIFIED
WE'RE DOING WE'RE CAUGHT THAT
THE SET THANK YOU. THANK YOU
APPROACH YOUR- OF. BUT AS WE
SAID THE FOCUS TODAY IS ON
SAFELY RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS
AND- AS WE DISCUSSED YESTERDAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE SUMMIT. FROM
VERY EARLY IN THIS PROCESS THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL HAS
BEEN ISSUING GUIDANCE FOR
SCHOOLS AND FOR CHILD CARE
SERVICES AND EARLY MARCH- MARCH
THE TWELFTH TO BE SPECIFIC AND-
WHEN WE FIRST PUBLISHED THE
FIFTEEN DAYS TO SLOW THE SPREAD
AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO ENGAGE-
IN THE SCHOOLING FROM HOME
WHERE. EVER POSSIBLE. FROM THAT
POINT FORWARD- CDC IS PUBLISHED
DECISION TREES ABOUT HOW
SCHOOLS CAN BEGIN TO DEVELOP RE
OPENING PLANS. AND JUST LAST
WEEK PUBLISHED NEW GUIDANCE FOR
K. TWELVE SCHOOLS- THE NEXT
WEEK- AS A- DR REDFIELD I CAN
ELABORATE- IN A FEW MOMENTS
THEY'LL BE ISSUING FIVE NEW
DOCUMENTS- LITTLE. RANGE FROM
PREPARING COMMUNITIES TO RETURN
TO SCHOOL SAFELY TO. DECISION
MAKING TOOLS FOR PARENTS AND
CAREGIVERS AND- TO CREATE A
SYMPTOM SCREENING
CONSIDERATIONS AS HIS CHILDREN
AND TEACHERS. ON A RETURN TO
SCHOOL- BUT- IS OF WE MADE
CLEAR YESTERDAY WILL MAKE CLEAR
AGAIN TODAY WE'RE HERE TO HELP-
AND NONE OF THE CDC'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE INTENDED.
TO REPLACE STATE LOCAL RULES
AND GUIDANCE ON THAT WHAT WE'VE
MADE CLEAR TO GOVERNORS. AND
THE STATE AND LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICIALS IS CDC STANDS DICK
AND TO WORK. WITH LOCAL
OFFICIALS AS THEY TAILOR THEIR
PLAN FOR RE OPENING SCHOOLS. OF
BUT WE'RE ALL COMMITTED TO
GETTING KIDS BACK IN CLASS. GET
IT PLEASURE MISSILE. WITH THAT
I WANT THE SECRETARY EDUCATION
TO REFLECT ON THE- ON THE
EFFORTS TAKING HERE THE
DEPARTMENT. SANCTIONS UNDER.
YOU COME FROM HER H. US BEFORE.
AFTER INSTRUMENTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER REST THANKS HOSTING
THE TASK HERE WE ARE SO GREAT
TO THE AND TO YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON DOING WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR STUDENTS YESTERDAY WE
HAD A REALLY GOOD AND IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AT THE WHITE HOUSE
WITH LOCAL LEADERS AND GREAT
TEACHERS AND PARENTS IT WAS
INSIGHTFUL AND INSPIRING AND AS
THAT MRS PENCE NOTED THESE PAST
FEW MONTHS PARENTS HAVE WORN
MULTIPLE HATS THEY REALLY ARE
OUR OUR OWN ON SOME HEROES AND
I MIGHT ADD BUT AS THE
PRESIDENT NOTED AS ARE THE
TEACHERS WERE OFF PLAYING DUAL
ROLES. SO TWO HELP THERE'S
LEARN SHE ALSO SAID MRS PENCE
ALSO SAID THAT AS WE DON'T
REOPEN BUSINESSES RESTAURANTS
THEATERS IN OUR COUNTRY WE
SIMPLY CAN'T LEAVE OUT OUR
SCHOOLS AND THAT IS SO CORRECT
STUDENTS CAN AND MUST CONTINUE
TO LEARN FULL TIME I'VE BEEN
REALLY INSPIRED BY THE
INNOVATIVE TEACHERS SCHOOLS AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
KEPT LEARNING GOING THROUGH
THIS PAST FEW MONTHS AND
THEY'RE GETTING READY TO DO IT
AGAIN THIS. ALL COUPLE UPGRADE
EXAMPLES THE END NOT HARLEM
AND- THE SURROUNDING BOROUGHS
IN NEW YORK SUCCESS ACADEMY
MOVED TO DISTANCE LEARNING IN
ONE WEEK USING MULTIPLE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS- TEACHERS
THERE INSISTED ON. IN OUT
LEARNING NEW MATERIALS RIGHT
ALONG WITH THEIR STUDENTS THE
STUDENTS WERE STILL GRADED THEY
MADE SURE ALL THE STUDENTS HAD
THE NEEDED TACK. THAT THEY DID
NOT MAYBE HAVE AT HOME INITIAL
LIKE. MIAMI DADE COUNTY. USES
EXISTING INSTRUCTIONAL
CONTINUITY PLANS TO MAKE A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION TO DISTANCE
LEARNING. THEY ADDED
INTERVENTIONS FOR STUDENTS WHO
WERE STRUGGLING- ALREADY BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. THE INTERNATIONAL
LEADERSHIP ACADEMY IN TEXAS
STARTED FROM THE MINDSET THAT
NOT LEARNING WASN'T AN OPTION
FOR ANY STUDENT. THEY DELIVERED
MULTI LINGUAL AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION CURRICULUM TO ALL OF
THEIR STUDENTS. THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF SCHOOLS AND DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT DID AN
AWESOME JOB OF TRANSITIONING
THIS SPRING. AND THERE WERE A
LOT IN WHICH I AND STATE SCHOOL
LEADERS WERE DISAPPOINTED IN
THAT THEY DIDN'T FIGURE OUT HOW
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS TO MANY OF THEM JUST
GAVE UP. AT THE CENTER FOR
REINVENTING PUBLIC EDUCATION
SAID THAT ONLY 10% ACROSS THE
BOARD PROVIDED ANY KIND OF REAL
CURRICULUM AND INSTRUCTION
PROGRAM. AND AS I SAID I I'VE
TALKED TO ALL THE STATE SCHOOL
CHIEFS AT LEAST ONCE MOST OF
THEM MORE THAN ONCE AND THEY'VE
TOLD ME THAT WHILE MANY OF THE
DISTRICTS THEIR STATE. HAVE
DONE WELL THROUGH THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS A NUMBER OF
THEM- THEY WERE VERY
DISAPPOINTED IN IN DOING NEXT
TO NOTHING. AND THEN. WE SEE AS
WE TALK ABOUT RE OPENING
SCHOOLS. THERE ARE SOME
CREATING FALSE PARADIGMS FOR
THE FALL AND HERE RIGHT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD THE DC AREA FERRIC
FAIRFAX COUNTY WHICH IS ONE OF
THE MOST. WELL FUNDED- I WOULD
CALL IT IN THE LEADS PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM IN AMERICA-
OFFERED FAMILIES A SO CALLED
CHOICE FOR THIS FALL. EITHER
ZERO DAYS IN SCHOOL FOR THEIR
STUDENTS FOR TWO DAYS. AND
THEIR SPRINGTIME. ATTEMPT AT
DISTANCE LEARNING WAS A
DISASTER. BUT I HAVE TO I GIVE
THIS AS AN EXAMPLE BECAUSE
THINGS LIKE THIS CANNOT HAPPEN
AGAIN IN THE FALL IT WOULD FAIL
AMERICA'S STUDENTS AND IT WOULD
FAIL TAXPAYERS WHO PAY HIGH
TAXES FOR THEIR EDUCATION.
ALTERNATELY IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF IF SCHOOLS SHOULD REOPEN
IT'S SIMPLY A MATTER OF HOW.
THEY MUST FULLY OPEN AND THEY
MUST BE FULLY OPERATIONAL AND
HOW THAT HAPPENS IS BEST LEFT
TO EDUCATION AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. I REALLY APPRECIATE
SOMETHING THAT SECRETARY ETS
ARE REITERATED YESTERDAY AT THE
WHITE HOUSE IT'S A SURGEON
GENERAL'S PRESCRIPTION FOR
HEALTH CARE AND I'M GOING TO
REPEAT IT AGAIN BECAUSE IT
BEARS REPEATING. FIRST ASK
YOURSELF WHAT'S YOUR INDIVIDUAL
CIRCUMSTANCE ARE YOU OR IS
SOMEONE IN YOUR HOME
VULNERABLE. SECOND WHAT'S GOING
ON IN YOUR COMMUNITY. IS THE
VIRUS WIDESPREAD OR IS IT
ISOLATED. AND THIRD THINK ABOUT
THE KIND OF SCHOOL ACTIVITY
THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT HOW TO
HOW TO ACCOMMODATE AND DEAL
WITH WHAT NEEDS TO BE IN PLACE
FOR THINGS TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
EDUCATION LEADERS NEED TO
EXAMINE REAL DATA FOR THEIR OWN
STATES AND COMMUNITIES AND
WEIGH THE RISKS. LOCAL LEADERS
IN EVERY COMMUNITY NEED TO ASK
THESE QUESTIONS AND CONSIDER
ALL THE RISKS. PHYSICAL HEALTH
AND SAFETY ARE FACTORS SO IS
MENTAL HEALTH. SO IS SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT. AND
POURTANT LES VERY IMPORTANTLY
SO ARE LOST OPPORTUNITIES FOR
STUDENTS PARTICULARLY THE MOST
VULNERABLE AMONG US AND
STUDENTS WITH DISABILITIES. THE
AMERICAN ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS
NOTED KEEPING SCHOOLS CLOSED
PLACES CHILDREN AND ADOLESCENTS
AT CONSIDERABLE RISK OF
MORBIDITY AND IN SOME CASES
MORTALITY. THE PEDIATRICS
GUIDANCE CONCLUDED THAT
EVERYONE SHOULD START WITH THE
GOAL OF HAVING STUDENTS
PHYSICALLY PRESENT IN SCHOOL.
FULLY OPEN AND FULLY
OPERATIONAL MEANS THAT STUDENTS
NEED A FULL SCHOOL YEAR OR
MORE. AND IT'S EXPECTED IT WILL
LOOK DIFFERENT DEPENDING ON
WHERE YOU ARE. WHAT'S CLEAR IS
THAT STUDENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES NEED MORE OPTIONS.
I'VE TALKED A LONG TIME ABOUT
THE NEED TO RETHINK EDUCATION.
AND THE END TO EXPAND EDUCATION
OPTIONS FOR ALL STUDENTS THIS
MOMENT REALLY DEMANDS ACTION.
IN AMERICA ALWAYS WAS AND IS
AND ALWAYS WILL BE A COUNTRY OF
DOERS. WE ARE CONFIDENT THAT
WITH GRIT AND DETERMINATION AND
A MEASURE OF GRACE WE CAN AND
WILL DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR ALL
THE STUDENTS ARE NATION. THANKS
VERY MUCH. THE REPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE PRESIDENT
FIRST AND FOREMOST I WANT TO
MAKE IT VERY VERY CLEAR THAT
THE GUIDANCE THAT CDC CONTINUES
TO PUT OUT FOR SCHOOLS K.
THROUGH TWELVE THE HIGHER
LEARNING IS INTENTIONAL. FOR
REAL OPINION KEEPING OUR
SCHOOLS OPEN THAT IT'S THAT'S
ITS PURPOSE. WE RECOGNIZE THAT
THERE'S A VARIETY OF UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES FOR DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS AND DIFFERENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. AND SO WE'VE
OUTLINED A NUMBER OF STRATEGIES
THAT. THOSE SCHOOLS THOSE
ADMINISTRATORS CAN USE TO
ACCOMPLISH THIS GOAL SAFELY.
BUT I MIGHT WANT TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT WHAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF CDC'S GUIDELINES. IS
TO BE USED AS A RATIONALE TO
KEEP SCHOOLS CLOSED. WE'RE
PREPARED TO WORK WITH EACH
SCHOOL EACH JURISDICTION TO
HELP THEM. USE THE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES THAT WE PROPOSE THAT
HELP DO THIS SAFELY SO THEY
COME UP WITH THE OPTIMAL
STRATEGY FOR THOSE SCHOOLS. I
THINK IT'S CRITICAL AND IT
WOULD BE PERSONALLY VERY
DISAPPOINTING TO ME AND I KNOW
MY AGENCY. IF WE SAW THE
INDIVIDUALS FOR USING. THESE
GUIDELINES AS A RATIONALE FOR
NOT RE OPENING OUR SCHOOLS. I
THINK THERE'S A SERIES OF-
DIFFERENT- ADDITIONAL
GUIDELINES THAT WE ARE. ABOUT
TO PUT OUT TO HELP REALLY- WITH
THE K. TO TWELVE COMMUNITY-
PARTICULARLY AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL TO HELP. OPEN SAFELY. A
GUIDELINES ALSO THE COME OUT OR
CONSIDERATION DOCUMENTS FOR
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS
GUIDELINES FOR SCHOOLS TO HELP
THEM UNDERSTAND HOW BEST TO. DO
SYMPTOM SURVEILLANCE AND
CHARACTERIZE SIMPSON'S IN THE
SCHOOLS AS A TOOL AND
GUIDELINES TO REALLY WORK AT
HOW AND THE INS AND OUTS OF
USING FACE MASK IN THE SCHOOL
SETTING. AS WELL AS FINALLY
SOME GUIDANCE IN THE HELP THE
SCHOOLS HAVE SYSTEMS WHICH THEY
CAN MONITOR THEIR PROGRAMS BUT
I WANT TO CLOSE BY JUST
REITERATED AGAIN THAT THE
PURPOSE OF CDC'S GUIDANCES
REMEMBER ITS GUIDANCE. IT'S NOT
REQUIREMENTS AND ITS PURPOSE IS
TO FACILITATE THE REOPENING AND
THE KEEPING OPEN THE SCHOOLS IN
THIS COUNTRY BECAUSE OF AS THE
VICE PRESIDENT SAID IT IS
CRITICAL. THAT WE GET THE
SCHOOL TO OPEN DO IT SAFELY
WE'RE PREPARED TO WORK WITH ALL
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
SCHOOLS TO THEM FACILITATE
THEIR DEVELOPMENT OF THEIR OWN
UNIQUE. AND ACCOMPLISHMENT OKAY.
THANKS DOCTORATE TO. OPENING UP
SCHOOLS RIGHT THING TO DO FOR
KIDS. SO THEY DON'T FALL BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY AND ALSO SO THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE IN NEED OF
SERVICES. SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILDREN CHILDREN WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES TRISTIAN NIEVES
HAD THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
RECEIVE AT THE SCHOOLS. THAT'S
IMPORTANT THOUGH FOR PARENTS
AND FOR WORKING FAMILIES AND
THE WAY I A SECRETARY OF US
BELIEVED TO BE HERE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR TO SPEAK
ABOUT THE IMPACT ON. ON AS WE
PUT AMERICA BACK TO WORK BUT
NOT MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO.
HAVE SINGLE PARENTS BACK IN THE
WORK FORCE IT'S ESSENTIAL THAT
WE GET OUR SCHOOLS OPEN AS
WELL. AND SO I WANTED SECRETARY
SCALIA AND THEN OF COURSE
OCCURRED HHS FINISHER REMARKS.
BEFORE WE GO TO QUESTIONS.
SECRETARY. THANK YOU. MR VICE
PRESIDENT'S GOOD TO BE WITH YOU
ALL TODAY- FOR REASONS THAT UP
SECRETARY DIVORCES MENTIONED
VICE PRESIDENTIAL COURSE HAVING
OUR SCHOOLS OPENED UP IS SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION BUT AS THE VICE
PRESIDENT HAS SAID. IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AS WELL TO WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WHO NEED TO BE ABLE TO
STRUCTURE THEIR WORK DAYS IN A
PREDICTABLE MANNER- IN THE
EXPECTATION THAT SCHOOLS WILL
BE OPENING THEIR CHILDREN WILL
BE ABLE TO BE IN SCHOOL SO THAT
THE PARENTS IN TURN CAN HAVE A
PARTICULAR SCHEDULE THE
PAPERING. WORKPLACE OF COURSE
THAT'S- BURTON'S TO HOP OUR
BUSINESS PLACES AS WELL AND
THAT'S IT'S REALLY. CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT TO OUR- NATIONAL RE
OPENING ONE STUDY HAS SUGGESTED
THAT IF WE- CLOSED ALL OUR
SCHOOLS AND DAY CARE FOR JUST A
MONTH JUST HYPOTHETICALLY IF WE
IF WE DID THAT. THE IMPACT ON
US PRODUCTIVITY WOULD BE OF THE
ORDER FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
GIVES YOU SOME SENSE OF THE
IMPACT. ON HAVING OUR SCHOOLS
CLOSED CAN HAVE INTERNATIONAL
RECOVERY I DID WANT TO. MENTION
A COUPLE OF GROUPS IN
PARTICULAR. TO THIS IS. AND
FIRST BOUGHT LOWER WAGE WORKERS
ONE OF THE TRIUMPHS OF THE
ECONOMY TO BE JOY UNTIL THE
VIRUS CAME WAS HOW WELL. LOWER
INCOME- MEN AND WOMEN WERE
DOING IN THE WORKPLACE WE AS
YOU KNOW HAD UNEMPLOYMENT THE
TIDE OF FIFTY YEAR LOW WE HAD
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS HISPANIC
AMERICANS AND OTHERS. AND I AND
WE HAD RISING WAGES WAGES
ACTUALLY ROSE ABOUT 15% FOR
LOWER INCOME. OF MEN AND WOMEN
DURING THE FIRST THREE YEARS OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION
UNFORTUNATELY KNOW PEOPLE
OBSERVED A SIT LOWER INCOME
WORKERS WHO STAND. UP ADVERSELY
AFFECTED BY SOME SHOT WE'VE HAD
A IN RESPONSE TO THE A
CORONAVIRUS. UNEMPLOYMENT AMONG
THE LOWER INCOME WORKERS HAS
BANNED ALL HIGHER THAN FOR
OTHER POPULATIONS. THEREFORE
FOR THEM HAVING SCHOOL THREE
OPEN SOON THEY TULSA
PREDICTABLE TO BE ABLE TURN THE
WORKPLACE. IT'S GOING TO BE. A
HOLDS DINNER. LAST MOVIE I'M SO.
TELL I THINK MANY OF US KNOW
EVEN TO. THERE ARE BEING PLACED
ON MOTHER'S WHO WERE GET A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER STATE. A LOT
LATER BUT TO GET MORE DONE TO
AROUND DOT KERRY FOR THEIR THE
INTER. BUT FOR LOWER MEN WOMEN
FIVE THAT ARE OFTEN IS NOT EVEN
AVAILABLE AN INSECT ON THE
CONCRETE ON. WERE WOMEN WHO.
STUDIES WHEN I THINK OF THE
EXPERIENCE OF MANY THIS
REFLECTS THAT IT'S- WOMEN IN
THE HOUSEHOLD WHO QUITE OFTEN
APPEAR THE LARGER BUT BIRD WHEN
IT COMES TO NOT CARING FOR
CHILDREN'S STUDIES SHOW. US AND
UP AND. YOU PRIOR TO CO WILL
UNDER GREAT IN THE- WERE
ENJOYING WAS. THE EMPLOYEE RATE
FOR WOMEN- ON THE- RATE FOR
WOMEN WAS ACTUALLY LOWER THAN
FOR MEN RIGHT BEFORE THE VIRUS
CAME BUT- UNFORTUNATELY IN THIS
IS US. TO DISAGREE BEEN
TRACKING WE SEE THAT. THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE FOR WOMEN NOW
IS HIGHER. THAN IT IS UP FOR ME
NOW WE MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN
JUNE THE VICE PRESIDENT MINS
EXTRAORDINARY BOB'S REPORT. WE
PUT SEVEN HALF MILLION
AMERICANS BACK TO WORK. ARE YOU
JUST TWO MONTHS AND THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE RATE FOR
WOMEN DROPPED. NEARLY 3% IN
JUNE BUT STILL WE HAVE-
IMPORTANT WORK TO DO AND WE
KNOW. THAT WORKING WOMEN WILL
HAVE A HARDER TIME. IN BACK TO
THE WORKPLACE THEY CONTINUE TO
TRY CHILD CARE. MUCH RATE THAN
IT WAS ISN'T NOT A TO WORK. IN
SO FOR TO. SCHOOL. WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT JUST TO WRAP UP I IN
SUCH A SENSITIVE PACE AND
STRUCTURE. OF OUR NOW LIFE IS
BUILT AROUND THE EXPECTATION
THAT OUR YOUNG PEOPLE I WILL BE
IN SCHOOL ARE IN THE EIGHTY IN
PERSON DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR
THAT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR THEM
BUT IT'S ALSO VITALLY IMPORTANT
FOR THEIR PARENTS IN THAT SENSE
SO CRITICAL TO HIS RE OPENING.
OF EATING VERY WELL
ECONOMICALLY BUT TO KEEP GOING
WITH OUR SCHOOLS UP IN THE
FALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
RESEARCHER. WELL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR VICE PRESIDENT FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OF THE PRESIDENT'S
ALL OF AMERICA APPROACH TO
COMBATING THE VIRUS AND FOR THE
FOCUS THAT YOU'RE NOT PUTTING
ON GETTING OUR KIDS LEAD BACK
TO SCHOOL. FROM HHS'S
PERSPECTIVE REOPENING SCHOOLS
SAFELY MAY BE THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT THING THAT WE CAN DO
TO SUPPORT HEALTHY FAMILIES
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. ALL
DECISIONS ABOUT UNDERTAKING
ACTIVITIES DURING COVID
NINETEEN. HAVE TO LOOK AT RISK
AS A CONTINUUM NOT A BINARY
QUESTION. STATES AND SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN THINK ABOUT THE
SAME THINGS THAT WE URGE
INDIVIDUALS TO THINK ABOUT. AS
SECRETARY THE BOSS NOTED OUR
SURGEON GENERAL HAS COME OUT
WITH THIS PRESCRIPTION. FOR
HEALTH. ASK YOURSELF ♪THREE%-pCE
YOU IS THERE SIGNIFICANT
COMMUNITY TRANSMISSION OF THE
VIRUS IN YOUR AREA. WHO ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN MUST LET
MUCH LESS SUSCEPTIBLE TO SEVERE
OUTCOMES FROM THE VIRUS THAT
ADULTS. AND WHAT ACTIVITIES ARE
WE LOOKING AT. THERE ARE MORE
AND LESS RISKY ACTIVITIES FOR
SCHOOLS KEEPING KIDS IN THE
SAME CLASSROOM VERSUS CHANGING
CLASSES. LARGE GATHERINGS AND
DOING ACTIVITIES OUTSIDE
WHENEVER POSSIBLE. REOPENING
SCHOOLS COMES WITH SOME RISK
BUT THERE ARE RISKS TO KEEPING
KIDS AT HOME TO. AT HOME KIDS
ARE BENEFITING FROM SOCIAL
STIMULATION THEY MAY BE FALLING
BEHIND IN LEARNING. THEY MAY BE
MORE VULNERABLE TO ABUSE THAT
GOES UNREPORTED BY THE
MANDATORY REPORTERS IN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEM. THEY MAY NOT BE
GETTING SPECIAL SERVICES YOU
MAY NEED. THEY MAY NOT BE
GETTING THE NUTRITION THAT THEY
GET AT SCHOOL. IT MAY BE
DIFFICULT FOR PARENTS TO GET
BACK TO WORK AT SECRETARY
SOLENO TO. THIS ISSUE LIKE SO
MANY CONSIDERATIONS AROUND
SAFELY RE OPENING. ISN'T ABOUT
HEALTH VERSUS THE ECONOMY BUT
ABOUT HEALTH VERSUS HEALTH. ALL
OF THIS IS WHY THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS IS
STRONGLY RECOMMENDED BEGINNING
WITH THE GOAL OF HAVING
STUDENTS PHYSICALLY PRESENT. IN
SCHOOL. THIS SCHOOL IS THE
RIGHT WAY TO USE THE EXTENSIVE
GUIDANCE CDC HAS PUT OUT TO
HELP EACH STATE AND SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK THROW A SAFE
REOPENING. LAST WEEK WE PUT OUT
GUIDANCE AROUND TESTING FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS. THIS
GUIDANCE LIKE OUR GUIDANCE FOR
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
OFFERS RECOMMENDATIONS FOR HOW
AND WHEN STUDENTS TEACHERS AND
STAFF SHOULD BE TESTED. WHILE
CDC DOES NOT MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION IN FAVOR OF
UNIVERSAL TESTING. IT'S A
PERFECTLY APPROPRIATE
SURVEILLANCE TECHNIQUE WHERE
THE CAPACITY EXISTS AND
CAPACITIES GROWING ALL THE TIME.
WE TALK TO COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THEY'RE ABLE TO
USE THEIR RESEARCH LAB CAPACITY
WITH THE POOLING OF MULTIPLE
SAMPLES. TO TEST THEIR WHOLE
STUDENT BODIES AND STAFF
FREQUENTLY THANKS TO REGULATORY
FLEXIBILITY THAT CMS AND THE
FDA HAVE PROVIDED. MANY OF THE
LEADERS WE HEARD FROM YESTERDAY
AT THE WHITE HOUSE SCHOOL RE
OPENING SUMMIT ARE DOING
TESTING BEFORE RETURNING TO
SCHOOL. AND THEN SENTINEL
SURVEILLANCE. ON TOP OF THAT
THE MEASURES WE RECOMMEND
UNIVERSAL LIKE KEEPING A
DISTANCE WEARING A FACE
COVERING. AND FREQUENT HAND
WASHING. ARE EFFECTIVE AND CAN
BE APPLIED IN THE COLLEGE OR
THE K. THROUGH TWELVE SEC. WE
PUT UP THE CDC GUIDANCE TO
ENABLE AND SUPPORT STATES AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN RE OPENING
SAFELY. WE WANT THEM TO USE THE
TOOLS AVAILABLE TO REDUCE RISK
AND WE'LL BE PUTTING OUT MORE
GUIDANCE ON HOW SCHOOLS CAN USE
EACH OF THESE TOOLS SUCH AS
FACE COVERINGS. ON TOP OF THAT
I WILL. SET OF TOOLS IS
EXPANDING ALL OF THE TIME. JUST
YESTERDAY WE SIGNED A NEW
AGREEMENT WITH REGENERON TO
PROVIDE NEARLY HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS AND SUPPORT FOR A
PROMISING THERAPEUTIC ALL THE
WAY TO MANUFACTURING HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOSES BUT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE. THE INITIAL
DOSES ENDING APPROVAL WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AS SOON AS THE END OF
THE SUMMER OR EARLY FALL. THAT
IS THE FIRST OF A NUMBER OF
THERAPEUTIC AGREEMENTS THAT WE
WILL DO AFTER THE PROVINCE
OPERATION WARP SPEED INITIATIVE.
THANK THERAPEUTIX ALREADY
BEING. EVERY DAY BY OUR HER
RELIC HEALTH CARE WORKERS. I
WANNA THANK THESE HEROES WHO
CONTINUE TO PUT THEMSELVES AT
RISK CARING FOR THOSE SUFFERING
FROM THE VIRUS. WE KNOW MANY
FRONTLINE WORKERS HAVE GOTTEN
SICK. AND WE L. SOME HAVE GIVEN
THEIR LIVES INCLUDING SOME OF
MY EMPLOYEES IN THE END HEALTH
SERVICE. AND AMERICA IS DEEPLY
GRATEFUL. IT IS BECAUSE WE ARE
MAKING PROGRESS AGAINST THE
VIRUS AND LEARNING MORE ABOUT
IT EVERY DAY THAT WE CAN TALK
ABOUT HOW TO BRING AMERICA'S
KIDS AND TEACHERS BACK TO
SCHOOL. SAFELY WE HAVE THE
TOOLS TO DO IT. AND IT HAS TO
BE A TOP PRIORITY. SO THANK YOU
TO PRESIDENT TRUMP. AND THE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR PUTTING SUCH
A FOCUS ON THIS VERY IMPORTANT
ASPECT OF OUR ROAD TO RECOVERY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT
HERE PLEASE. VICE PRESIDENT AND
THE PRESIDENT'S CALL TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS IS THERE A SITUATION IN
SOME STATES THAT THE HEALTH
SITUATION DOESN'T ALLOW FOR
THAT'S WHERE YOU'D BE
SUPPORTIVE OF SOME STATE'S
CONTINUING DISTANCE LEARNING
AND WE NOW SEE THE PRESIDENT
THREATENING TO CUT OFF FUNDING
FOR SCHOOLS IS THAT A SERIOUS
THREAT WHAT WOULD THAT LOOK.
LIKE WELL THE PRINCIPAL AND OUR
APPROACH TO THIS CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN TO. PROVIDE
FEDERAL SUPPORT AS AS STATE'S
MANAGE THEIR OWN RESPONSE. AND
WHAT I CAN TELL YOU THIS IN THE
WEEKLY REPORTS AND WE PROVIDE
GOVERNORS WE'RE WE'RE DOWN TO
THE COUNTY LEVEL IN TERMS OF
WHERE THE NEW CASES ARE WHERE
THE POSITIVITY. LAWS AND I
THINK WE WOULD COUNT FOR THE
FACT. THAT WELL WE HOPE. WE
HOPE EVERY SCHOOL IN AMERICA IS
ABLE TO OPEN. THIS FALL THERE
MAY BE SOME STATES AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES THAT. THE GIVEN
CASES POSITIVITY AND THAT
COMMUTE MAY EDGED PAST. THERE
IS SEVEN DAY. FOR CERTAIN WHEN
THE TWO AND WILL BE VERY
RESPECTFUL OF THAT BUT THE
PRESENCE MAKE CLEAR THOUGH IS
THAT WE THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPERATIVE THAT EVERY STATE AND
TERRITORY IN THIS COUNTRY-
MAKE- MAKE- STEPS AND TAKE
STEPS RATHER TO. GET KIDS BACK
IN THE CLASSROOM TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE- WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT- THE EVERY STATE
NOW HAS THE ABILITY TO DO THAT-
BUT FOR THOSE INDIVIDUAL
COMMUNITIES THAT MAY BE SEEING.
OUTBREAKS WILL WORK WITH THEM
GIVE THEM THE GUIDANCE AND THE
SUPPORT TO BE ABLE TO IMPLEMENT
THE POLICIES THAT THEY DEEM ARE
MOST APPROPRIATE OUR OUR
MISSION HERE IS TO SAFELY.
REOPEN OUR SCHOOL YOU'VE HEARD.
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR TOWN IS NOT
JOE A- I'M NOT BEHIND
ACADEMICALLY IT'S ABOUT ALL THE
VITAL SERVICES THE CHILDREN
RECEIVE AT OUR SCHOOLS IT'S
ABOUT WORKING FAMILIES IT'S
ABOUT OPENING UP AMERICA AGAIN
AND SO WE'LL CONTINUE TO DRIVE
ON THAT. ON YOUR SECOND POINT
ACT I WOULD TELL YOU THAT. AT
THIS POINT- THINK 90% OF
EDUCATION FUNDING COMES FROM
THE STATE'S ROUGHLY TEN
PERCENT. DEPENDING ON STATE'S
BUDGETS COME FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- IT IS WE WORK WITH
CONGRESS ON- THE NEXT ROUND OF
THE STATE'S SUPPORT- WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING FOR WAYS. TO
GIVE STATES- A STRONG INCENTIVE
AND ENCOURAGEMENT TO GET KIDS
BACK TO SCHOOL. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THAT THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED THIS MORNING
THAT HE DISAGREES WITH THE
CDC'S VERY TOUGH AND EXPENSIVE
GUIDELINES FOR RE OPENING
SCHOOLS DO YOU ALSO DISAGREE
WITH THOSE GUIDELINES AND ARE
YOU CONCERNED THAT YOU MAY BE
PUTTING THE HEALTH OF STUDENTS
AND TEACHERS AT RISK BY TRYING
TO MEET THE PRESIDENT'S DEMANDS
A REAL. WELL WHEN I SPOKE ABOUT
THAT. OF THIS MORNING AND- I
THINK OF WHAT YOU WILL SEE IN
THE COMING DAYS WHAT YOU HEARD
FROM DR REDFIELD. YESTERDAY AT
THE SUMMIT AND AGAIN TODAY'S
VERY CONSISTENT. WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S OBJECTIVE AND THE
CONCERNS THESE RACE WE DON'T
WANT. AND THE GUY FROM CDC TO
BE A REASON WHY SCHOOLS DONALD.
WE WANT TO PARTNER WITH
STATE'S. OF WITH LOCAL
EDUCATION OFFICIALS WITH
GOVERNORS WAS LOWER. OFFICIALS
FIND A WAY TO MEET THEIR NEEDS
TO OF. INSTEAD OF. A STATE THIS
MORNING WAS SIMPLY REFLECTIVE
OF THAT. DESIRE IN BUT WE
REMAIN VERY CONFIDENT THAT AS
WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES WE'RE SEEING NOT JUST
NOT JUST K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION I MEAN. SEVEN STAY.
TO TURN RESERVE ALREADY
PUBLISHED PLANS AND GUIDES FOR
RE OPENING THEIR SCHOOLS AND WE
REITERATED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
EARLIER THIS WEEK AND AGAIN- AT
THE SUMMIT YESTERDAY THE WHAT
WE'RE REALLY HERE TO PARTNER
WITH THEM TO ACHIEVE THAT I
THINK WHAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
SAYING THIS MORNING. IS THAT IF
THERE ARE ASKED TO THIS IS
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE
PRESCRIPTIVE OR THAT SERVE TO
AS A AS A BARRIER TO KIDS
GETTING TO SCHOOL WE WANT WE
WANT THURSTON AND LOCAL
OFFICIALS AND EDUCATION LEADERS
TO ANOTHER ONE TO WORK WITH
THEM- TO SUPPORT THE MEASURES
THEY'RE PUTTING INTO PLACE BUT
I. THANK I. YEAH AMERICAN KNOWS
THAT WOULD SAFELY REOPEN OUR
SCHOOLS AND- WE JUST WANT WE
WANT TO WE WANT WE WANT AS THE
PRESIDENT THIS MORNING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WHAT WE'RE DOING
DOESN'T STAND IN THE WAY OF
DOING THAT. BIDEN GOES. IS THE
FOLLOW UP WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF CHILDREN NO
SHOOTING THE GUIDANCE BE TOUGH
AND SHOULD NO EXPENSE BE SPARED.
WELL I'M YES BARBOURFIELDS
SPEAK TO THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN I AND I TELL
YOU AS A AS A PARENT AS MUCH AS
YOUR VICE PRESIDENT. AND THE
HEAD OF THIS IS FORCE I'VE BEEN.
I'VE BEEN GRATEFUL FOR IT IS
THAT THE APART FROM HAVING AN
UNDERLYING HEALTH CONDITION
CHILDREN DO NOT APPEAR TO BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO SERIOUS ILLNESS
FROM THE CORONAVIRUS- DOCTOR
BURKE'S INSPECTOR THAT
STATISTICALLY ON A GLOBAL BASIS
AND THAT'S BEEN A BLESSING FOR
AMERICANS AND AMERICAN
FAMILIES- AND SO WE AS THIS IS
SECRETARY CHARGES SAID WE KNOW
THAT THE RISK OF SERIOUS
ILLNESS. TWO CHILDREN IS VERY
LOW. AND THERE MEASURES WE CAN
PUT INTO PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE DON'T. WE DON'T SEE
THE- THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS OR
OUTBREAKS IN INDIVIDUAL SCHOOLS
BY HAVING CHILDREN LEARN A
SINGLE CLASSROOM OR LEARNING
OUTSIDE AS OFTEN AS POSSIBLE
NOT TO INTO LARGER SETTINGS. IN
THIS IS ALL THE GUIDANCE OF THE
CDC PUTTING FORWARD- BUT- BUT
I'M LET DIRECTION. SPEAK TO
THAT BECAUSE OF. WE REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN OPEN THE
SCHOOL SAFELY- MINISTER OF WHAT
WE'VE SEEN IN TERMS OF. OUTCOME
CHILDREN- AND- AND ALSO THE
CARD MEASURES THE WE THINK WE
CAN FOR INTO EFFECT. TO PREVENT
THE SPREAD. THANK YOU MR VICE
PRESIDENT I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE-
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS TO OPEN THE
SCHOOLS ARE REALLY BASED ON THE
SOUND PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND HEALTH OF CHILDREN. I THINK
YOU HEARD ALREADY FROM SOME OF
THE SPEAKERS THERE'S
SUBSTANTIAL HEALTH CONSEQUENCES
THAT WE'VE SEEN AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF SCHOOLS BEING
CLOSED WHETHER IT'S ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. WITH
ACCESSING THE TRADITION CLEARLY
WE KNOW A LOT AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE DON'T REACT
EMOTIONALLY. BUT WE ACT BASED
ON DATA CLEARLY THE ABILITY OF
THIS VIRUS TO CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
ILLNESS. IN CHILDREN IS VERY
VERY VERY VERY LIMITED WE KNOW
OF THE POST AMID AN
INFLAMMATORY DISEASE THAT
YOU'VE HEARD ABOUT BUT IT'S
VERY RARE. BUT IN GENERAL THIS
VIRUS DOES NOT CAUSE
SIGNIFICANT ILLNESS IN CHILDREN
SECONDLY AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT UNLIKE INFLUENZA.
WHERE ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CONCERNS AS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
SHOW THAT IT'S REALLY SCHOOLS
AND CHILDREN THAT BECOME THE
INSTRUMENT OF TRANSMISSION.
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITY WITH
INFLUENZA WE REALLY DON'T HAVE
EVIDENCE THAT CHILDREN ARE
DRIVING THE TRANSMISSION CYCLE
OF THIS. THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING AS WE RE OPEN SCHOOLS.
AND THEN AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
WE'RE PREPARED TO WORK WITH
EVERY SCHOOL IN EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO HELP THEM FIND THE-
RIGHT. MAKE YOUR STRATEGIES FOR
THEM TO DO THIS SAFELY. OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE NOT
REQUIREMENTS. AND THEY'RE NOT
MEANT TO BE PRESCRIPTIVE WE
HAVE LOTS OF DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
ON HOW THE SCHOOLS CAN PUT IT
TOGETHER. WHAT WHAT WE WOULD DO
WANT TO REITERATE AS WE RE OPEN
SCHOOLS. IS REMEMBER THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING THE
VULNERABLE. THAT WE WILL BE
STRONGER. IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH SIGNIFICANT
COMORBIDITIES- INDIVIDUAL WHAT
HAPPENED TO BE ELDERLY WITH
COMORBIDITIES- WE WANT TO LIMIT
THOSE INDIVIDUALS THEIR
INTERACTIONS IN GENERAL SOCIETY
INDEPENDENT SCHOOLS. THANKS ONE
MOMENT SAY JUST ALSO IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION I
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT EVERY
AMERICAN REVIEW THE STATEMENT-
ISSUE FIVE THE. AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS- THAT-
THAT RELEASED A SPLIT AND
IMPORTANT REPORT INDICATING
THAT. THEY'RE REAL- PHYSICAL
AND MENTAL CALLS FOR CHILDREN
TO BE DEPRIVED OF THE IN CLASS
ROOM SETTING ONE UP REGISTER ME
TRICIA AND TWO CHILDREN THAT
HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS. WE HEARD
FROM UP. AFTER MCCAIN'S CATS
THAT SOME SEVEN MILLION
CHILDREN IN AMERICA THAT DEAL
WITH MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
SERVICES IN THE COUNSELING THEY
RECEIVE THEY RECEIVE AT THEIR
SCHOOLS AND WE WANT TO PUT THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF OUR
KIDS FIRST AND GIVEN THE FACT
THAT CHILDREN AS DR REDFIELD
SAID AND- DID NOT APPEAR TO BE
SUSCEPTIBLE TO. THESE OUTCOMES.
ON THE VIRUS. WE WANT TO PUT
THEIR THE TOTAL OF THEIR HEALTH
AND THERE WELL BEING FORWARD.
AND THAT ALL TELLS US IT TELLS
PRESIDENT TERMS THIS TASK FORCE.
THAT MEANS WE NEED TO GET OUR
KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL. PLEASE
MAKE. ARTICULATED THE PROBLEM
THE MYRIAD RISKS THAT STUDENTS
FACE TO FACE DAY OUT OF SCHOOL
COME THE FALL. BUT WHAT'S THE
PLAN WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S
SPECIFIC PLAN IN TERMS OF
INCREASED TEST CONTACTOR RACING
INCREASE VP IF IT'S NEEDED TO
SUPPORT THE SCHOOLS YOU WELL
KNOW SCHOOLS WANT BUILT FOR
STUDENTS TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
BUILT. IN AS MANY KIDS AS
HUMANLY POSSIBLE WHICH IS ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS LIKE EFFECTS YEAH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT YORK. TEXAS
THEY HAVE MOVED TO A HYBRID
APPROACH SOME FOR BURNING SOME
PERSON LEARNING SO WHAT'S THE
PLAN IN THE QUESTION FOR BROOKS
ABOUT KIDS IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
AT. THE PLAN IS TO CONTINUE TO
DO WHAT WE DONE FROM. BEGINNING
AS YOU HEARD AGAIN THIS MORE
WE'RE CORRECT I BELIEVE
THIRTEEN I MILLION TESTED A
BEEN. ALL ACROSS THIS. HURDEN
ANDROGYNOUS. EXTRAORDINARY
COMMITMENT AND JUST ONE
COMMUNITY ALONE AND WHAT WE'VE
CONVEYED TO GOVERNORS. IS
WHATEVER SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
GET KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. MAKE SURE
YOU HAVE THE TESTING RESOURCES.
WE'RE CURRENTLY- EDUCATING. THE
STATE'S ON POSSIBILITY WORK
COMMERCIAL LABS IMPOSSIBILITY
WAS CALLED COOLING. AND SO THAT
LITERALLY. THERE COULD BE ONE
TEST RUN ON SAY TEN SAMPLES AND
THERE ARE PARTICULAR
UNIVERSITIES THAT ALREADY HAVE
BUILT INTO THEIR PLANS THE IDEA
OF TE. ALL THERE'S SET THE
BEGINNING. ACADEMIC YEAR AND
THAT MEANS A LOT THANK. CLEAR
WHETHER IT'S TESTING WHETHER
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
OR OTHER REESE. AT THE WELL WE
STAND READY TO PROVIDE THOSE
THREE. TO THE STATE AND WE
REITERATED THAT ONCE AGAIN. AND
TO THE GOVERNORS- BUT- THE GOOD
NEWS IS BECAUSE OF THE HISTORIC
MOBILIZATION OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S INITIATED- WE LITERALLY
HAVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF.
SUPPLIES OF PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT FIFTY NINE THOUSAND.
VENTILATORS IN THE STRATEGIC
NATIONAL STOCKPILE OF TESTING
AND SCALING ALL ACROSS AMERICA
AND OF WE KNOW THE KIND THE
SCHOOL YEAR WILL WILL BE READY
TO MEET THOSE NEEDS. BUT
QUESTIONS. WHAT'S INFECTION
RATE AMONGST WHAT'S THE VERY
LATEST IN TERMS OF. LIKE YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF HOW THE VIRUS
PRESENTS IN CHILDREN HELP
CHILDREN TRANSMITTED BY RISK TO
OLDER ADULTS NEARLY A THIRD OF
TEACHERS ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
ARE AGE FIFTY AND OLDER AND
WHAT'S THE BEST PRACTICE IN
TERMS OF TESTING CHILDREN I'VE
NEVER HEARD OF A CASE WHERE IT.
THIS TEST FOR CARBON NINETEEN.
THOSE ARE ALL GOOD QUESTIONS
AND I THINK IT REALLY COMES TO
THE THAT EVIDENCE BASED ON WHAT
WE HAVE AS FAR AS TESTING IN
CHILDREN SO IF YOU LOOK ACROSS
ALL OF THE TIME THAT WE'VE DONE
AND WHETHER WE WHEN WE HAVE THE
AGE PORTION THAN THE- TESTED
FOR. UNDER TEN. SO WE'RE
PUTTING INTO PLACE OTHER WAYS
TO. GET TESTING RESULTS FROM
THEM AND LOOKING AT ANTIBODY IN
THAT DISCARDED SAMPLES AND TRY
TO FAIRLY FIGURE THIS OUT
BECAUSE PARENTS HAVE REALLY
DONE AN AMAZING JOB OF
PROTECTING THEIR CHILDREN I
THINK AMERICANS HAVE DONE A
GREAT JOB IN KEEPING INFECTION
RATES LOW IN CHILDREN UNDER THE
SHELTERING TIME AND KEEPING
INFECTION RATES WERE RIGHT NOW
IN THIS NEW IS ORIGINALLY I
THINK WE SAW. GREAT PROTECTION-
PEOPLE COMORBIDITIES WE ARE
WORRIED NOW THAT AS THE CASE IS
SPREAD THAT'S GETTING TO THE
OLDER PARENTS AND THE
GRANDPARENTS AND I CALL ON
EVERY MULTI GENERATION
HOUSEHOLDS GET STEP THAT
PROTECTS THOSE IN THE HOUSEHOLD
AND WE DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
CHILDREN INVOLVED WHAT IS IT AT
LEAST FOR THE DC PART. CATION
IT'S PROTESTS. CHILDREN ALSO
FROM GETTING A TO THE BY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE ARE TWO
WITH BUT IT IS WE KNOW THAT
THEIR CHILDREN IN AMERICA WITH
CANCER AND GETTING UNDERGOING
CHEMOTHERAPY. BUT WHEN YOU ASK
THAT QUESTION. SO PROTECTED
THEIR CHILDREN AND REMEMBER
EARLY ON WE SAID TEST IF YOU
HAVE SYMPTOMS AND NOW WE KNOW
THAT IF YOU'RE UNDER EIGHTEEN
MAJORITY OF YOU DON'T HAVE
SYMPTOMS. AND SO REALLY
FIGURING OUT TEN UNIVERSITIES
WORKING AROUND THE COUNTRY ON A
SALIVA TEST SO. EASY EASIER FOR
CHILDREN TO PUT SALIVA IN A
TUBE IS BASICALLY WHAT WE CALL
SPITTING IN A TUBE. ARE
SPINNING THROUGH A STRAW INTO
EIGHT TWO I AM LOOKING AT THAT
KIND OF INNOVATION AND TESTING
AND WHAT. HAD ROLL GERARD'S
BEEN WORKING ON IT VERY HARD IS
AN AGENT BASED TESTED. AND
GETTING THAT IT MEANT INTO
ABOUT GLOBAL AREAS UP INCOME
THIS IS LOOK. I AND OTHER. BOSS.
JUST DID YOU THAT WOULD. EASE
THE TASK AND HE LIVE A SO ALL
OF THOSE ARE BEING WORKED ON
THAT'S WHY WE- PUSHING. ON THE
ANAGEN OR HEARD ME ABOUT IN A I
WE'RE PUSH ON THAT BECAUSE WE
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT FOR
TESTING OF STUDENTS IN TEST
UNIVERSITIES. WE HAVE THE- OUR
DATA IS SKEWED. ORIGINALLY TO
PEOPLE WITH SYMPTOMS AND THEN
SKEWED TWO ADULTS OVER
EIGHTEEN. AND SO WE ARE LOOKING
VERY CLOSELY INTO THAT CATEGORY
BY USING OUR ANTIBODY TEST.
RESEARCHERS OKAY I THINK THE
VICE PRESIDENT COVER THAT
INCREDIBLY WELL WE KNOW THAT
MORTALITY RATE AND UNDER TWENTY
FIVE FROM THE CDC DATA IS LESS
THAN POINT ONE PERCENT- AND SO
THAT HAS BEEN HOLDING BUT UNTIL
WE KNOW HOW MANY HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE
THAT THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
MORTALITY IN CHILDREN WITHOUT
COEXISTING DISEASES. THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR RIGHT
NOW IS TO REALLY MAKE SURE IF
ON TURNER TURNED EVERY ROCK NOT
JUST THAT DEEP. MISTRUST
PRESIDENT. WE ALL KNOW THE CDC
GUIDELINES ARE NOT REQUIREMENTS
THIRTY DOLLARS RIGHT ANDERSON.
THE PRESIDENT WHEN HE CALLS IT
TOO TOUGH OR IMPRACTICAL-
MAKING IT EASIER FOR AMERICANS
AND- FOR SCHOOL OFFICIALS TO
IGNORE THAT ADVICE. BOLTON I
IDEA I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE
THAT GOVERNORS. AND STATE
EDUCATION OFFICIALS AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE GOING TO
IMPLEMENT POLICIES THAT THEY
THINK ARE IN THE BEST INTEREST.
OF CHILDREN AND FAMILIES AND- I
THINK PRESIDENT SENTIMENTS THIS
MORNING I THINK IS OF IT IS
SHARED. BUT WIDELY BY THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND CERTAINLY-
BY MEMBERS OF THIS TASK FORCE
WE WANT TO MAKE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT. THAT SCARES ME THE
GUIDANCE THEY WERE ISSUING IS
NOT TO SUPPLANT. OF THE LAWS
THE RULES THE REGULATION OF THE
DECISIONS AT THE STATE LEVEL
IT'S MEANT TO CREATE-
ESSENTIALLY A RANGE OF OPTIONS-
IN WHAT WE MADE CLEAR TO
GOVERNORS- GOVERNORS CALL THIS
WEEK SPECIFICALLY WAS THAT. WE
ARE PREPARED AT THE CDC AT TO
SIT DOWN WITH STATE OFFICIALS
AND TO WORK THROUGH THEIR
PLANNED- AND BE ABLE TO ADVISE
AND- AND DIALOGUE WITH THEM
ABOUT ABOUT THE BEST WAY
FORWARD BUT I. I MUST TELL YOU
THAT- IN THIS ROLE OVER THE
LAST FOUR MONTHS A I'VE BEEN
IMPRESSED. BY GOVERNORS IN BOTH
POLITICAL PARTIES- AND- HEALTH
OFFICIALS IN ALL OF OUR STATES
AND OUR TERRITORIES WITH THEM
WHERE THEY PUT THE HEALTH. OF
THEIR PEOPLE FIRST AND BUT I
MUST ALSO SAY THAT I HAVE. A
GREAT SENSE TALKING TO
GOVERNORS AND A GREAT SENSE OF.
THE THIS IS OF SOME EMERGING
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE HAPPEN AND
GOVERNORS ARE HEARING THAT THEY
KNOW THAT AND THAT'S WHERE YOU
HAVE FORTY SEVEN STATES THAT
HAVE ALREADY ISSUED PLANS OR
GUIDELINES AND WE'RE GONNA WORK
WITH THEM TO MAKE THE SYRIA I
THINK I. ONE FOR DR REDFIELD.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY THE
PRESIDENT IS STARTED
THREATENING TO CUT FUNDING.
FROM SCHOOLS AT A TIME WHEN
EDUCATORS ARE SAYING THEY NEED
MORE SO THEY CAN SAFELY RE OPEN.
OKAY ONE FIRST AND FOREMOST
IT'S WHAT YOU HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT IS JUSTICE
TERMINATION. TO PROVIDE THE
KIND OF LEADERSHIP FROM THE
FEDERAL LEVEL IT SAYS WE'RE
GOING TO GET HER KIDS BACK TO
SCHOOL. BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THEY BELONG. AND WE KNOW BASED
UPON- WHAT WHAT ARE BEST HEALTH
OFFICIALS TELL US THAT WE CAN
DO THAT IN THE SAFE AND
RESPONSIBLE WAY- BUT DURBIN TO
BE CLEAR THE CURRENT CARES ACT
PROVIDED THIRTEEN POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. TO SUPPORT-
EDUCATION EFFORTS IN STATES IN
THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC WE'RE
GONNA WORK WITH CONGRESS WE
EXPECT. THE BIT NATIONAL
SUPPORT THERE BUT- PRESENCE IS
VERY SERIOUS FOR ALL THE
REASONS THAT WE DISCUSSED TODAY.
HE BELIEVES. AND WE BELIEVE
IT'S ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL. FOR
CHILDREN'S ACADEMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND FOR THEIR SOCIAL AND
EMOTIONAL. AND HEALTH AND
NUTRITION NEEDS TO BE BACK. IN
THE CLASSROOM AND WE'RE GONNA
PROVIDE THE LEADERSHIP. OF FROM
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO DO THAT.
BUT THAT BEING SAID I. WILL
TELL YOU I THINK I SENSE A
GREAT DESIRE AMONG GOVERNORS
AROUND THE COUNTRY TO FIND A
WAY FORWARD- AND WE MADE IT
VERY CLEAR TO THEM THAT. WE'RE
PARTNERED WITH THEM PROVIDING
THEM WITH THE RESOURCES TO
IMPACT THAT ALSO THE SUPPLIES.
DESCRIBING IT AS A LOCAL
DECISION SO SHOULD IT BE UP TO
THEM TO DECIDE IF THEY CAN
SAFELY REOPEN AND NOT THE
PRESIDENT SAYING HE'S GOING TO
PRESSURE THEM TO DO SO. WELL I
I'VE- WE'RE GOING TO RESPECT
THOSE UNIQUE COMMUNITIES THAT
MAY HAVE CHALLENGES THAT HAVE
RISING CASES ARISING
POSITIVITY. AND BUT I THINK YOU
LOOK AT THE NATION AS A WHOLE.
AND FOR THE PRESENT IN THE
UNITED STATES MADE CLEAR C.
THANKS. AS WE RE OPEN AMERICA
WE NEED A REAL MEREKA SCHOOLS.
JUST AS PRESIDENT SAID EARLY
THIS PANDEMIC THREE WANT TO GET
OUR- PLACES OF WORSHIP BACK
OPEN AGAIN WHAT YOU'RE SEEING.
PRESIDENT PROVIDERS IS
LEADERSHIP- END. WHAT WE'RE
PROVIDING FOR THE WHITE HOUSE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE. ITS
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE GOVERNORS
OF THE STATE HEALTH OFFICIALS-
BECAUSE WE JUST GOT TO GET WE
GOT TO GET OUR KIDS BACK I- I
HAVE TO TELL YOU THE BEST
EXPERT I KNOW THIS TOPIC IS MY
WIFE KAREN. AND THE BOOK AT THE
SUMMIT YESTERDAY VERY
COMPELLINGLY UP ABOUT HEALTH A
LOT OF OUR KIDS ARE HURTING
AFTER. THE STRUGGLING
LONELINESS WITH SOCIAL
ISOLATION THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS SPOKE ABOUT THAT
A VERY FORCEFUL STATEMENT FROM
PEDIATRICIANS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY THE SAID WE GOT TO GET
HER KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL. AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE WHAT YOU'RE GONNA
SEE K. ONE IS THE PRESIDENT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
LEADERSHIP I EXPECT THE- IS THE
DEBATE IN CONGRESS GOES FORWARD
ABOUT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WERE
LOOK TO BUILD IN INCENTIVES.
FOR STATES TO GO FORWARD BUT-
PRESENCE MADE IT CLEAR- AND I
THINK MOST PARENTS IN AMERICA
AGREEMENT. THAT WE GOTTA GET
OUR KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL AND WE
GOT TO GET BACK INTO THE
CLASSROOM. WE CAN DO IT THIS IN
A RESPONSIBLE WAY. THAT'S OKAY.
GOT DIRECT BILL YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE GUIDANCE THAT THE CDC
IS PUT OUT IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU
THINK IT IS IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF STUDENTS AND WAYS
TO SAFELY REOPEN SCHOOLS SO FAR
SO ARE YOU GOING TO CHANGE THAT
GUIDANCE BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
SAID THAT HE DOES NOT. LIKE IT.
WELL I THINK I JUST WANT. WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE. TO WORK WITH
LOCAL STATES- AND JURISDICTIONS
I THINK THE GUIDANCE THAT WE
PUT OUT- GIVES A SERIES OF
DIFFERENT STRATEGIES FOR THEM
TO CONSIDER. WHAT IS THE MOST
APPROPRIATE IN THEIR UNIQUE
SITUATION. TO ADOPT AGAIN I
WANT TO COME BACK TO THE GOAL
WHEN THE GOAL OF THIS IS TO GET
SCHOOLS RE OPENED I DID MENTION
AND I WANT TO REITERATE. THAT
GOALS JUST NOT A GOAL TO REOPEN
SCHOOLS THAT'S A GOAL BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THAT'S THE BEST
PUBLIC HEALTH INTEREST. OF THE
STUDENTS FEDERATION FOR. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO DEVELOP AND
EVOLVE OUR GUIDES TO MEET THE
NEEDS. OF THE SCHOOLS IN THE
STATES THAT WE- CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE THAT ASSISTANCE TO.
THANK. I'M SORRY I CAN'T HEAR
YOUR QUESTION. OKAY WHAT THAT
GUIDANCE RECOMMENDS THAT STATE
THAT SCHOOLS HAVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING OF STUDENTS SIX FEET
APART AND THAT'S WHY THE
SCHOOLS ARE ADOPTING THESE
SEPARATE MODELS IS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T FEEL THEY CAN KEEP SCHOOL
STUDENTS FEET APART IN THEIR IN
THEIR BUILDING SOME JUST WANTED
THAT PARTICULAR PART OF THE GUY
INTO SOME YOUR RETHINK WOULD
YOU SUPPORT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING INSIDE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE I THINK
ARE HAVING. TODAY WE JUST. GOT
TO BE TOUGH THAT'S THE REASON
WHY WEEK. OF CDC IS GOING BE
ISSUING A NEW SET OF TOOLS FIVE
DIFFERENT. DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
BEGINNING IN AND- OF MORE
CLARITY ON THE GUIDANCE GOING
FORWARD BUT WE KNOW EACH SCHOOL
SYSTEM- IT HAS A- UNIQUE
CAPABILITIES- DIFFERENT
FACILITY. AND UP. WHAT PARENTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY SHOULD KNOW
IS THAT- WE'RE HELP. WE'RE HERE
TO WORK WITH THEIR GOVERNORS
WITH THEIR LOCAL EDUCATION
OFFICIALS. TO GET OUR KIDS BACK
TO SCHOOL I MEAN THE TRUTH THE
MATTER IS THAT AS WE OF. WE RE
ONE OF AMERICA'S HEALTH. WE GOT
A REAL PERSON FOR THE WORLD OF
OUR KIDS THEIR ACADEMIC
ADVANCEMENT FOR WORKING
FAMILIES A BUT ALSO AS YOU
FORGET A DAY. A TO CONTINUE THE
MOMENTUM THAT WE SEE IN THIS
ECONOMY THAT WE SAW LAST WEEK
WITH NEARLY FIVE MILLION JOBS
CREATED. I ONE PROMISING
AMERICAN PEOPLE WE'RE GONNA
STAY FOCUSED AT THIS TASK FORCE
ON SAVING LIVES MEETING THE
NEEDS OF OUR STATE AND OUR
HEALTH CARE WORKERS I'M
PROTECTING THE VULNERABLE. AND
AMERICA'S. AUTOMATE SCHOOLS
WORK AND WORSHIP SO THANK YOU
ALL VERY MUCH TALK TO YOU IN A
FEW DAYS.
AFTER. AT. YEAH.